[Music]
the great old ones in HP lovecrafts
cthulu mythus are ancient and Powerful
Cosmic entities that play a central role
in the law in the call of cthulu the
cultist worship these beings claiming
them to predate humanity and arriving
from the stars the distinction between
great old ones and outer go is somewhat
ambiguous with entities like nip
considered an outer God despite
significant Earthly involvements Azo and
yokoto are generally seen as OU Gods no
problem with that while there are
conflicting views on beings like zazuo
and shab narath despite this complexity
the term great old one often refers to
entities like Gulu and satua while OU
Gods encompasses older Cosmic entities
so here in this video we will showcase
10 10 of these great old ones from the
expanded culu myths so let's get to it
number one chak noron first appearing in
Frank Longs the horror from the Hills
this great old one is said to be a
vampiric entity that has several minions
known as his brothers chocar for is a
vampiric creature with the appearance of
an elephant humanoid hybrid it possesses
a leech-like mouth at the end of its
trunk a dis shaped mouth a foot in
diameter it displays remarkable speed
for its size which is bigger than that
of an elant utilizing its Trung to drain
the blood of its victims chakar Fon and
its siblings are integral parts of a
single extraterrestrial super organism a
great old one living in an inaccessible
Cavern nestled in the Pyrenees between
Spain and France number two gogoro this
great old one is a creation of Robert E
Howard seen in Howard's children of the
night and is further explored in the
gods of Bal sagath it is portrayed as a
Titanic black toad like creature a monr
try with a malevolent glare however its
form is not fixed and can change based
on the Observer worst nightmares the
adaptability adds an extra lay of horror
as golgoroth can manifest in many ways
and that is most terrifying to whoever
encounters it descriptions also mention
tentacles scales batlike wings and other
nightmar features the book of Avon
places gor's layer under mount antartis
and Antarctica at the South Pole
residing in an inaccessible region for
humans number three noock and YB these
are twin great old ones that are often
clued in together in one narrative they
are called the Sons of shop nurat while
in another account by Avon they are a
product of the andri ginus zag Zuko
splitting in two becoming male Nu and a
female YB but according to HP Lovecraft
one thing is for sure nug is the parent
of cthulu and YB is the parent of saaga
they are 3 m or 10 ft in size and appear
to be amorphous and horrific like shop
nurat they they are entrusted with
clearing the Earth for the great Old
One's return using two devices called
the furnace of YB and the torch of Nag
to accomplish these
purposes number four gatan TOA gatan TOA
is a great old one introduced in HP lrft
935 tale out of the aons although the
story was Ghost ridden described as a
colossal Abomination its appearance is
so grotesque that those who behold it or
its image are turned into living mummies
lcraft portrays GTH
as a monstrous deity or a Petron demon
brought to Earth in ancient times by
extraterrestrials from the planet Yugo a
planet also associated with the Migo
while the creature is deemed
Indescribable it seems to combine
features of an octopus and an elephant
exhibiting both scaly and wrinkled
characteristics all the while
maintaining an amorphous form it was
widely worshiped in ancient times before
the M continent was sunk and then later
in ancient Egypt China and in the New
World number five neoka neoka also known
as the Haunter of the red Abyss or the
thing that should not be is a great old
one within the cthul myths debuting in
Henry Cut's work the Salam horror neoka
is portrayed as a formless entity
comprised of unidentifiable adhesive
black substances it possesses the
ability to extend Tentacles from this
Mass to interact with its surroundings
according to the URS book the
Necronomicon the only method to banish
neur back to its own dimension once it
has been summoned here involves a ritual
incorporating an ank a peculiar Elixir
and a mysterious and esoteric
incantation number six RM shikor also
known as the White Worm this is a great
old one created by Clark Ashton Smith
seen in his story a short story called
The Coming of the White Worm this entity
is depicted as an immense pale worm with
a gaping mouth and eye sockets that
perpetually oo blood the creatures
Origins are mysterious hinting at a
possible origin From Another Dimension
it sustains Itself by consuming the
bodies souls and knowledge of formidable
Sorcerers as it devours more its size
increases reaching proportions of
mountains Additionally the White Worm
possesses the ability to induce a
profound Slumber in those nearby and
control their actions while in this
state number seven yig yig the father of
serpents is a great old one that was
introduced in the HP Lovecraft revision
story The Curse of yig yig is described
as an odd half anthropomorphic Devil
with a highly arbitrary and capricious
nature the deity has a unique blend of
humanoid and serpent-like
characteristics reflecting its role as
the father of serpents while the
specific physical attributes may not be
extensively detailed the general image
is that of a creature with both human
and snake likee elements one notable
aspect of VI's character is his
ambivalent nature unlike some of the
Holy m devent entities in the cthulu
myths Yik is portrayed as having a
complex
personality number eight SATA saaga also
known as the sleeper of enai is an
entity in the cthul Mythos expanded
universe he is a creation of clar Ashan
Smith in the short story The Tale of
satura zeras he was adopted by Lovecraft
in his work the Whisperer in darkness he
possesses a Squatty pot Bell physique
resembling more of a monstrous to than a
scary inter find deity his entire body
was clad in short fur creating an
indistinct impression of both bat and
sloth-like beings while still having the
looks of a toad his eyes are globular
meaning really round and he has a
peculiar tongue that pops out from his
bulbous mouth contributing to his
overall unusual and disgusting
appearance number nine cthulu he is a
being made by Lovecraft in his short
narrative the call of cthulu he's
described as a powerful octopus like
great old one with draconic wings a
humanoid body and a head that has
multiple tentacles and tendrils in his
mouth he is as of the present day in a
Domin deathlike Slumber trapped within
his submerged city of eara beneath the
Pacific Ocean so he's first of all the
namesake of the mythus mainly due to his
Fame not because of his power in fact he
is comparatively weak in comparison to
the others like the outer Gods
nevertheless he has a great following on
Earth and communicates with people via
his telepathic call that P the minds of
people he is the spawn of nug which was
in turn sprouted by shop nurat the outer
God and he has quite a number of spawns
himself like katilla and gatan TOA there
is so much to speak about this
particular old one but that's for
another video and as for now let's get
to the last entry and number 10 hter
hter is a renowned and enigmatic great
old one in the cthul myths although
often associated with HP Lovecraft it is
only mentioned in one of his stories the
whisper in darkness The Entity was
originally conceived by Ambrose Beers in
haa the shefer where hter is portrayed
as a god of shepherds described as a
great old one and The Offspring of Y Soo
he is considered the half brother of
cthulu the entity manifests through
various avatars including the feaster
from afar depicted as a black shrivel
flying creature with tentacles ending in
razor Shar talents another well-known
Avatar of his is his manifestation as
the King in Yellow
so those are the 10 great old ones of
the cthulu myths and if you like this
video then watch this other one as well
and if you're more interested in other
movie monsters and creatures then check
out our Channel as well we might just
have things that you haven't seen or
thought about like subscribe and we'll
see you in the next video take care fam